hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream schön dass ihr bei uns seid zwei
Tage noch dann startet die wohl
umstrittenste Fußballweltmeisterschaft
aller Zeiten die WM in Katha kurz vor
dem Start fragen wir uns wer hat auf
diese WM eigentlich Bock auf diese WM in
einem Land das die Rechte von Frauen
untergräbt und homosexuelle Männer oder
Frauen verfolgt und einsperrt wer hat
Bock auf diese WM deren Vergabe
durchgerubbte FIFA Mitglieder erfolgtest
und bei der im Vorfeld Menschen beim Bau
der Stadien gestorben sind es ist eine
komplizierte Diskussion mit vielen
verschiedenen Ebenen ja und auf jeden
Fall auch ein moralisches Dilemma vor
dem wir alle stehen wie umgehen jetzt
mit dieser WM die Spiele gucken oder
alles boykottieren was beschäftigt euch
dazu wie geht's euch zwei Tage vor
diesem Staat was habt ihr vielleicht
noch für offene Fragen unser Chat der
ist auch offen stellt gerne alles was
euch dazu beschäftigt
direkt rein oder per Mail an unsere
Mailadresse ZDF heute-live@zdf.de
vorab die Entscheidung die trifft
natürlich jeder für sich individuell wir
wollen aber heute noch mal Fakten
durchgehen Perspektiven aufzeigen mit
einer echt tollen Diskussionsrunde auf
die ich mich sehr freue dass einmal
Felix casalino der ist bei uns zu Gast
Stürmer in der Regionalliga West bei der
SG Wattenscheid 09 und auch
erfolgreicher Youtuber vom Kanal
freekickers wir schauen auch nach Katar
selbst auf die Stimmung und die
Arbeitsbedingungen von vor Ort mit
unserer Korrespondentin und außerdem
begrüßen wir bei uns Alena Büchs die
Vorsitzende des deutschen ETH Graz bei
uns und bei uns im Studio da ist Dario
Minden der zweite Vorsitzende der Fan
Organisation unsere Kurve hi David schön
dass du dabei bist guten Abend
im September dieses Jahres hast du einen
beeindruckenden Vortrag auf den
Menschenrechte Kongress des deutschen
Fußball Bundes gegeben und dort war der
katharische der deutsche Botschafter aus
Katar zu Gast und dem hast du deine
Meinung zu dieser WM aber mal so richtig
ins Gesicht gesagt und da gucken wir
jetzt mal rein
erlauben Sie mir vielleicht zwei
persönliche Worte
an den Botschafter als
Repräsentant des Staates Katar
vielleicht damit sie face to face
rüberkommen möchte ich Sie auf Englisch
sagen
genau ein Moment
and I love men ich bin ein Mann ich
liebe Männer ich habe seien Sie bitte
nicht schockiert Sex mit Männern das ist
normal
bitte gewöhnen sie sich daran oder
halten Sie sich raus aus dem Fußball
denn die wichtigste Regel im Fußball
lautet fußball ist für alle da
sind Männer
es ist egal ob du lesbisch bist oder
schwul er ist für alle für Jungs für
Mädchen und für alle dazwischen also
schaffen Sie die Todesstrafe ab
schaffen sie alle Strafen ab die sich
auf sexuelle Identität beziehen die
Regel das Fußball für alle da ist ist so
wichtig
we can not allow you to break it wir
können Ihnen nicht erlauben diese Regel
zu brechen egal wie reich sie sind sie
sind herzlich willkommen der
internationalen Fußballgemeinschaft
beizutreten und ein großes Turnier
auszurichten aber im Sport ist es nun
mal wie es ist sie müssen die Regeln
akzeptieren
[Applaus]
diese Worte und dieses Statement das
steht für sich wie hat eigentlich der
katarische Botschafter in Deutschland
auf dieses Statement reagiert
auch Herz mit Fassung getragen es war ja
ein längerer Vortrag die meiste Zeit auf
Deutsch da habe ich ja durchaus auch
Punkte gemacht wo auch nicken konnte
wenn es darum ging nicht so den Finger
auf Katar zu richten sondern auch auf
die eigene Verantwortung zu schauen auf
DFB und FIFA
und dann hat er da die die volle
Breitseite abbekommen und hat das mit
Fassung getragen und war auch hinterher
ganz höflich zu mir hinterher bei einem
bei einem Gespräch oder genau das
Gespräch gesucht und hat da ähm ja
übliche talking points nochmal
rausgehauen also
sie for yourself es wird gar nicht so
schlimm sein und man soll erstmal
hingehen und ja es hat leider nicht sehr
belastbar weil wir viele unabhängige
Berichte kennen die die genau sagen dass
die Situation doch sehr schlimm ist ja
genau über diese vermeintliche Offenheit
und über alle Themen weiter rund um
diese WM der diskutieren wir gleich
später in der Sendung auch noch weiter
mit dir vielen Dank für den Moment wir
wollen jetzt aber eben auf diese
vermeintliche Offenheit die Kata auch
zum Beispiel in
Situation wie mit Dario beschreibt
schauen und da zeigt uns Christian Volk
jetzt aber die diskriminierende und
menschenverachtende Realität die in
Katar gelebt wird
es ist ein Gespräch das um die Welt geht
der katarische wm-botschafter Harley
Salman will mit dem ZDF über
Homosexualität sprechen in Katha ist
schwul sein Haram also verboten ich bin
kein strenger Muslim aber warum ist es
heran es ist ein geistiger Schaden
ein Sprecher des Organisationskomitees
bricht das Interview ab auch
Fußballprofis sind entsetzt
es ist einfach eine völlig inakzeptable
Äußerung gewesen und spiegelt so ein
bisschen Weltbild wieder glaube ich aus
einem anderen Jahrtausend da möchten wir
uns klar von distanzieren die FIFA
äußert sich nicht doch
Menschenrechtsorganisationen warnen
Homosexuelle sogar vor einer wm-reise
wir haben immer wieder dokumentiert dass
schwule Männer Transgender Frauen
verfolgt werden geschlagen werden dass
ihnen die Haare abgeschoren werden dass
sie zu Geständnissen gezwungen werden
also diese Lage ist für die ganze queer
Community wirklich katastrophalen der
katarische wm-botschafter sieht seine
homophoben Aussagen aus dem Zusammenhang
gerissen er schreibt später jeder sei in
Kata willkommen aber die Kultur und
Religion des Landes ändere sich nicht
für die Weltmeisterschaft
und wir schauen jetzt noch mal in das
Land Katha und schalten dazu unserer
Reporterin Korrespondentin golini atai
sie ist ZDF Studioleiterin in Kairo und
aktuell für uns vor Ort in Doha hallo
godini
wir haben das gerade gesehen auf der
einen Seite behauptet Katha Zitat jeder
Mensch sei hier willkommen egal welcher
Herkunft egal welcher Sexualität auch
der deutschen Innenministerin Fasern
wurden Sicherheitsgarantien gegeben für
offen homosexuelle oder queere Menschen
bei der WM sie seien sicher Frage an
dich wie sicher können wir uns denn aber
sein dass diese Sicherheitsgarantien
auch eingehalten werden
ich glaube nicht dass es jetzt im
letzten Moment zu einer Kehrtwende kommt
was diese sogenannten
Sicherheitsgarantien angeht aber das
Signal das in dieser Hinsicht gegeben
wurde war von Anfang an doppelt angelegt
zum einen hat tatsächlich die deutsche
Innenministerin von Garantien gesprochen
aber das wurde im gleichen Atemzug
ergänzt von den cataris vom Emir selbst
der gesagt hat alle sind hier willkommen
alle die sich für unsere Kultur
interessieren alle die sich für unsere
Werte interessieren und es wurde immer
wiederholt jeder der diese Werte
respektiert ist hier willkommen also es
drängt sich ein bisschen der Eindruck
auch wenn man dieses doppelte Signal
immer wieder sieht und hört und liest
das ist darum geht kommt aber provoziert
uns nicht mit eurem anders sein reizt
uns nicht und lasst uns alle zusammen
friedliches Fest erleben aber nutzt
diese WM nicht um irgendwelche
Demonstrationen hier zu veranstalten
oder
zärtlichkeitsbezeugungen in der
Möglichkeit zu zeigen
Kollege wir sehen das auch bei dem
Hintergrund da ist schon einiges los
viele Lichter viele Menschen die wir
sehen die Stimmung die werden wir uns
gleich noch mal weiter anschauen schauen
wir jetzt noch mal auf bilder wie diese
die hier aktuell auch im Netz kursieren
vermeintliche Fans aus verschiedenen
Nationen England Deutschland Argentinien
sollen sie zeigen die eine vermutlich
ausgelassene Stimmung auch zeigen sollen
der Vorwurf steht aber im Raum dass das
von Katha bezahlte sogenannte fake-fans
sind oder auch Gastarbeiter die im Land
leben die bezahlt werden die dadurch die
Straßen ziehen was weiß du darüber und
welche Stimmung nimmst du aktuell bei
dir in Doha war
also ich habe keine schriftlichen Belege
dafür dass es fakefriends gibt ich sehe
nur ziemlich viele Anzeichen ich habe
zum Beispiel gestern und heute mit
arabischstämmigen zugewanderten
sogenannten expertsziel gesprochen die
mir erzählt haben dass in der
Vergangenheit das hat der in den letzten
Jahren sehr viele Sport-Events in Katha
gegeben in der Vergangenheit eben zum
Beispiel für ein kostenloses mal oder
andere Vergünstigungen tatsächlich hier
gebeten wurden katarische landesstracht
anzuziehen und dann in die Stadien zu
kommen oder in die sportwerkstätten zu
kommen und insofern denke ich dass es
ein System dass wir schon gesehen haben
dass wir hier schon erlebt haben und das
wahrscheinlich auch während dieser WM
und im Vorfeld dieser WM auch so
angewandt wurde es gibt viele
Kennzeichen darauf dass die Stimmung
hier angeht ich befinde mich gerade hier
in Katara das ist ein wenig von der
Stadtmitte entfernt ein Stückchen
aufgeschüttetes Land sehr schön
gestaltet und es gibt hier beeindruckend
viele Einheimische die hierher gekommen
sind und das ist so eine Art fröhliche
Volksfeststimmung also ich würde sagen
so langsam läuft es an auch wenn wir
jetzt nicht allzu viele internationale
Fans bis jetzt gesehen haben getroffen
haben
kuline danke für diese Einblicke ein
weiteres Thema ist das Thema
Pressefreiheit da steht Cutter auf dem
119 von insgesamt 180 Plätzen also
ziemlich weit unten wie frei könnt ihr
da gerade als Team vor Ort berichten
das ist Einschränkungen gibt es erleben
wir immer wieder
sei es dass wir z.B mit lokalen Teams
drehen und da natürlich die berechtigte
Angst die berechtigte Sorge da ist dass
wir Menschenrechtsthemen anschneiden
dass wir bestimmte sensible Themen dann
drehen das könnte für diese
Einheimischen Teams den Verlust der
Existenzgrundlage bedeuten dass sie
sogar ausgewiesen werden aus dem Land
und deswegen ist da eine entsprechende
Angst doch immer wieder zu spüren und
dass die Reaktionen auf uns angeht
erlebe ich immer wieder bei unseren
interview-anfragen das gesagt wird oh
deutsches Fernsehen nee also wir haben
da einiges verfolgt was uns nicht
gefallen hat insofern können wir ihn
leider kein Interview geben solche
Aussagen werden zum Beispiel bei
lateinamerikanischen oder afrikanischen
Fernsehteams nicht gemacht dort wird die
WM auch wesentlich positiver
wahrgenommen es wird doch wesentlich
positiver berichtet dazu kommt dass ja
die ganzen Dreharbeiten hier für uns ein
logistischer Kraftaufwand sind wir haben
zwar zwei Akkreditierungen aber ein ganz
ganz vielen Orten in vielen Stellen der
Stadt über allem Land müssen wir
zusätzliche Akkreditierungen beantragen
zum Beispiel wenn wir in der neuen Metro
drehen wollen also das ist nicht ganz
einfach für uns auch Interviews mit
offizieller hat es bislang nicht gegeben
wir hoffen darauf dass sie trotzdem noch
stattfinden in den nächsten Tagen wir
können auch ganz kurz noch mal gemeinsam
auf eine Szene und Bilder schauen die in
den vergangenen Tagen durchs Netz ging
ein dänischer Reporter soll bei seinen
Dreharbeiten auch von katarischen
offiziellen daran behindert werden er
soll sogar festgenommen worden sein wir
haben das die Kamera wurde verdeckt
hinterher so so heißt man habe sich die
haben sich die katarischen offiziellen
dafür dann auch entschuldigt
du warst in den vergangenen Wochen
unterwegs hast du auch gerade gesagt
auch für eine Dokumentation für das ZDF
Arabiens Traum von der Zukunft da warst
du nicht nur in Vater unterwegs sondern
auch in anderen arabischen Staaten und
das was du gerade auch schon gesagt hast
diese andere Sichtweise das sagen ja
auch Kataris zum Beispiel als Kritik an
den Westen das bei all den Themen ist
ihr Zitat ihr schaut dann nur durch eure
westliche Brille drauf ihr müsst auch
Verständnis für unsere Kultur haben wir
machen doch schon so viele Fortschritte
was genau meinen Sie damit was hast du
da erlebt
ja tatsächlich steht immer wieder
der zwischen Blicks im Feld im Raum es
wird immer wieder gesagt wenn ihr euch
den Fußball anschaut dann bedenkt bitte
dass es hier um den Weltfußball geht und
das in weiten Teilen der Welt ist und
die Frauenrechte sogar noch schlechter
bestellt ist als in Katar ebenso die
Minderheitenrechte es wird immer wieder
darauf verwiesen dass es ein junges Land
ist das ist am Ende der ersten
Entwicklungsphase steht dass tatsächlich
sehr viele Reformen jetzt hier
unternommen worden sind zum Beispiel
dass sie internationale
Arbeitsschutzorganisation hier ein Büro
beziehen konnte zum Beispiel das
Arbeiter bei Jobwechsel und jetzt mehr
Möglichkeiten haben zum Beispiel dass
hier ein Ex kein exit Visa mehr brauchen
wenn sie das Land verlassen das sind
natürlich Reformen die erst 2021
eingeführt worden das heißt das wird
eine lange Zeit brauchen bis sie auch
wirklich durchgesetzt werden aber es
wird immer wieder darauf verwiesen dass
es hier diese Reformen gegeben hat im
Vergleich zu den Nachbarländern z.B zu
den Emiraten gibt es hier zum Beispiel
die Möglichkeit länger arbeitsfreie
Zeiten zu haben aufgrund der Sommerhitze
ist ja ein ganz entscheidender Faktor
beim Arbeitsschutz während es zum
Beispiel in den Emiraten längst nicht so
liberal gehandhabt wird mit den
Arbeitszeiten das sind tatsächlich
valide Punkte und viele wünschen sich
hier dass das auch berücksichtigt wird
dass es bewürdigt wird
daran dass es das sind immer wieder
Punkte der Auseinandersetzung auch wenn
wir den Leuten hier begegnen und
Berichte machen Eindrücke von goline zu
ZDF Studioleiterin in Kairo und aktuell
vor Ort Endor herzlichen dank dir
ja wer hat Bock auf diese
Weltmeisterschaft das ist unsere Frage
heute und da kommen auch ganz viele
Kommentare schon von euch rein die
zeigen einen diffuses Bild bei Youtube
sagt zum Beispiel idded mayway es wird
konsequent boykottiert
CD der User sagt Einschalten ganz klare
Sache in dieselbe Kerbe geht das Killer
er sagt ein Bierchen und die WM gucken
aber nur die wieder auf der anderen
Seite schreibt niemand hat Bock auf die
WM also genau und diese Bandbreite
geht's auch bei dieser Diskussion die
wir jetzt hier bei ZDF heute live auch
weiter führen werden und zwar mit Dario
Minden bei uns im Studio zweiter
Vorsitzender der fanorganisation unsere
Kurve und darüber hinaus mit Felix
casalino er ist selbst Stürmer bei der
SG Wattenscheid 09 in der vierten Liga
in der Regionalliga West er ist auch
erfolgreicher Youtuber mit dem Kanal
freekickers die haben knapp 9 Millionen
Abonnenten und mit Alena Büchs die
Vorsitzende des deutschen Ethikrats die
zu dem Thema aber heute nicht aus der
Position des Ethikrats spricht sondern
als Privatperson hallo an alle ich finde
eine richtig tolle Runde und ich freue
mich sehr auf die Diskussion
hi zusammen es ist ein super schwieriges
Dilemma das haben wir schon
rausgearbeitet für viele die Liebe zum
Fußball auf der einen Seite auf der
anderen Seite aber eben die Menschen
rechtlichen Probleme des Gastgeberlandes
die man auch nicht
ignorieren darf ich möchte bei Ihnen
Frau Büchs beginnen vor welchem
ethischen Dilemma stehen wir da jetzt
zwei Tage vorher und wie halten Sie es
persönlich WM gucken oder nicht
ja das ist ein wichtiger Punkt zwei Tage
vorher also ich muss einmal echt vorweg
schieben das sind für diejenigen den
Fußball was bedeutet für die das wichtig
ist ja für die das im Freundeskreis für
die Lebensqualität was bedeutet es ist
ein echtes ethisches Dilemma wenn das
nicht interessiert der kommt in kein
ethisches Dilemma aber das wir jetzt
alle über diese Fragen nachdenken
das ist schon ein Problem denn die
Entscheidung ist 2010 gefallen ja da
hätte man diese ganzen ethischen Fragen
eigentlich überlegen und abwägen müssen
und jetzt stehen wir zwei Tage vorher
sozusagen als Endkonsumenten da und
müssen in unseren Familien und mit
unseren Freunden überlegen gucken wir
jetzt gucken wir nicht kaufen wir
irgendwelche Produkte die Verben oder
machen wir das nicht und das ist einfach
ganz blöd das heißt wir lösen jetzt
ethische Probleme in unserem
Alltagsleben aber die Rahmenbedingungen
die gibt's schon ganz ganz lange da sind
immer blöd und ich habe das in der
eigenen Familie also ich gucke gar
nichts ich für mich habe entschieden ich
kann das nicht anschauen für mich sind
diese ganzen Fragen von Menschenrechten
Frauenrechten Schule und so weiter das
ist einfach das zerstört mir jegliche
Freude und Liebe daran aber ich habe
drei echt sehr Fußball begeisterte Jungs
zwei Kinder die waren noch nicht mal
geboren als diese Entscheidung getroffen
wurde
und wir haben das dann halt diskutiert
und dann ist echt genutzt auch so ein
bisschen in der Familie um einfach diese
Fragen von wie geht man mit Arbeitern um
ja was ist eigentlich das Problem wenn
so ein großes Turnier das ja auch so
viel Aufmerksamkeit kriegt wenn das in
dem Land stattfindet wo man eben wo wo
ein schwuler Freund von uns Angst haben
müsste da irgendwie Händchen halten über
die Straße zu gehen und das kann man mit
Kindern schon sehr gut diskutieren und
wir haben entschieden dass bei uns die
Jungs nur sehr ausgewählt viele gucken
und dass wir uns bei jedem Spiel
überlegen dass wir uns eine
Menschenrechtsorganisation anschauen die
ein bisschen kennenlernen und dann eine
Spende machen ich weiß dass das
durchgewieselt ist ja aber noch mal das
dass die Lämmer kriegen wir jetzt nicht
gelöst es gibt kein richtig guten Weg
und das ist so eine Möglichkeit
vielleicht ein bisschen durchzukommen
danke dass ihr das persönliche Dateien
wir gehen später auch noch mal
vielleicht weitere Lösungs Aspekte ein
jetzt aber kurz noch mal die Frage an
dich Felix da klang gerade auch schon
bei der Antwort von Frau Büchs die Liebe
zum Fußball raus
als jemand Felix der sein Leben lang
Fußball spielt auch jetzt noch das auch
beruflich macht wie geht es Dir vor
dieser WM und wie handhabst du das
ja ich bin irgendwo auch total
enttäuscht weil ich finde so ein
Fußballfest in der Weltmeisterschaft
sollte eigentlich was sein worauf man
sich freut und auch jetzt gerade zwei
Tage vorher enorm Vorfreude verspürt und
das kann ich für mich einfach sagen dass
es nicht so ist ich hätte es gerne
anders aber es ist nicht so ähm und ich
auch ich stehe vor dem Dilemma jetzt ist
es bei mir so dass ich wirklich alles
bei mir im Leben und Fußball dreht Job
Hobby ähm und deswegen werde ich auch
ausgewählte Spiele schauen einfach auch
aus dem Gesichtspunkt dass mich der
Fußball interessiert es spielen zum Teil
die besten Spieler der Welt
gegeneinander da kann ich nicht
wegschauen da das interessiert mich
einfach weil es aber auch beruflich mit
mir zusammen hängt und ich auch auf dem
neuesten Stand sein möchte was bei der
WM passiert ist kann ich sein dass ich
auch Social Media drüber diskutiere und
auch Berichte was bei der WM abgeht ist
aber selbst nicht Schauer bei den
letzten Turnieren 2014/18 war es
grundsätzlich so ich habe mir wirklich
jedes Spiel angeschaut weil ähm und egal
ob es etwa dort gegen Ghana war oder
andere Spiele die vielleicht
fußballerisch nicht so qualitativ sind
wie wir jetzt hier zum Teil aus dem
Westen kennen und weil es mich einfach
interessiert hat und ich auch kleineren
Staaten und Ländern die Aufmerksamkeit
schenken wollen wollte und dass wir
dieses Jahr absolut nicht der Fall sein
ich werde wirklich nur Spiele schauen wo
es mich fußballerisch interessiert das
finde ich extrem schade ich hätte es
gern anders aber ja es geht finde ich
nicht anders als die in diesem Jahr
Dario auch du liebst den Fußball du hast
dich aber auch gemeinsam mit unsere
Kurve schon vor anderthalb Jahren zum
Boykott dieser WM sozusagen entschieden
dazu aufgerufen und auch einen
Kriterienkatalog veröffentlicht
vielleicht sagst du noch mal was sind da
die Gründe für euch und für dich auch
gewesen das so zu handhaben
ja eigentlich was gar nicht so genau auf
dem Balkon ziehend weil ich oder wir
fanden es manchmal auch ein bisschen zu
verknappt auf diese Ja oder Nein Option
also ich persönlich und die die Frage
der Sendung ich habe keinen Bock auf
diesen Mist und und ich schaue auch wenn
es mir weh tut schaue ich nichts davon
aber der Ansatz war da zu sagen
es ist fatal dass er DFB nie gesagt hat
wir erwägen den Boykott der DFB hätte
Bedingung stellen müssen andere auch
unter den Bedingungen fahren wir hin
sonst nicht dann hätte man wirklich
Druck ausgibt deswegen haben wir in der
Vergangenheit immer versucht diesen
Balkon nicht nicht ganz zur Seite zu
drängen sondern dass er ernsthaft
diskutiert wird leider wurde nie
ernsthaft diskutiert jetzt in den Sinne
von Sponsoren Medien und und Fußball
Teams boykottieren die der private bei
Gott ist eigentlich das bei Gott auch
großes Wort
das ist eigentlich wirklich jedem selber
überlassen und ähm ich persönlich habe
da eher so der Rangehensweise ich möchte
einfach nicht so weit abstumpfen wie
verrückt es auch ein bisschen
dargestellt hatte so möchte man nicht
alles ausblenden das ganze Drumherum
aber das ist eine rein persönliche Sache
ich erkläre jetzt niemanden
verantwortlich für für Leid und Elend
der sich das als Endverbraucher dann
anschaut ja absolut Frau Bück sie haben
da gerade auch schon zugenickt zu dem zu
dem Wort persönlicher Boykott ist es ein
großer Begriff damit habe ich sie
beobachtet haben sie gelegt also sehen
sie auch so
ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt was
der dafür gerade gesagt hat dass es
andere Institutionen gibt die ja viel
mehr Hebel hätten als unser einer der
auf dem Sofa sitzt also davon zu
sprechen der Effekt wenn jetzt einzelne
das nicht schauen ist wahrscheinlich
relativ überschaubar also es sei denn es
würden sein wirklich ganz ganz ganz
viele Menschen nicht gucken das hätte
wahrscheinlich dann schon auch ein
impact aber viel viel spannender sind
natürlich solche Institutionen wie ähm
Sport Vereinigungen international oder
auch Unternehmen die sagen sie gehen da
nicht mit ähm das sieht man zum Teil
schon auch also da gibt es Beispiele und
es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von recht
coolen Aktion dafür also man bietet
alternativ was an man nutzt das wieder
irgendwie rüber zu sprechen aber der
allerwichtigste Punkt ist noch mal
wir führen die Diskussion jetzt halt
ganz kurz vorher und da kann man
eigentlich kaum noch was reißen also
entscheidend ist es dann eben in den
Jahren davor und das finde ich es echt
eine verpasste Chance weil man hätte
wirklich darüber ja nachdenken können
gehetzt Schrauben gegeben aus
Deutschland oder aus Europa oder oder
eben international was hätte man da wie
hätte man das einfach nutzen können wenn
man wenn diese Entscheidung schon
getroffen wurde die ja wie gesagt der
problematisch war dann ist es wirklich
schade dass wir das jetzt erst so kurz
vorher besprechen auch da Dario hast du
gerade noch mal genickt und und stimmst
du auch zu genau aber ich würde noch
ergänzen dass wir jetzt zwei Tage vor
der Kata WM sind aber wir sind leider
auch Jahre vor den nächsten
katastrophalen Fehlentscheidung und
dafür ist es glaube ich schon sehr
wichtig wie wir jetzt auch als
Zivilgesellschaft mit diesem Turnier
umgehen und wenn wir zumindest im
deutschen Markt irgendwie signalisieren
können okay die die deutschen Fans die
Deutschen Konsumenten einer hässliche
Wort nehmen will die Tick ein bisschen
anders die haben da keinen Bock drauf
die ja das funktioniert nicht so wie wie
vielleicht in anderen
Ländern bei Newcastle United das
Saudi-Arabien eingestiegen und und sau
viele Fans haben sich total gefreut
jawohl Fisches Geld scheiß egal wo es
her kam dass der deutschen Markt so
nicht funktioniert dass wenigstens für
die Zukunft auch Sponsoren hierzulande
merken ah okay nee wenn ich mit der FIFA
zusammenarbeite dann ist es ja
eigentlich voll der Imageverlust und
solche Zeichen zu setzen ist jetzt für
Katar natürlich ein bisschen spät aber
leider gibt's die Kräfte die für Katar
verantwortlich sind nach wie vorhin in
Machtposition deswegen ja ist es doch
wichtig apropos Zeichen setzen da können
wir auf eine Aktion vom achten November
schauen und zwar von queren und
homosexuellen Menschen die haben sich
vor dem fifa-museum in Zürich getroffen
und sie haben da die Aktion knutschen
für Katar
ins Leben gerufen als Zeichen des
Protestes gegen die Vergabe der WM
erfolgt durch korrupte FIFA Mitglieder
und da einfach als Zeichen
für Menschenrechte und für
Gleichberechtigung hier haben wir die
Bilder des Protestes
bleiben wir bei den Zeichen die aber
auch von den Institutionen das Dario
hast Du angesprochen es hat Frau bürks
angesprochen gesendet werden in dem
Kriterienkatalog den ihr veröffentlicht
habt da habt ihr auch ein interessanten
Punkt wie ich fand mit aufgenommen und
zwar habt ihr an den DFB gerichtet
Gewinne bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft
bis 2027 nur bei nachweislicher
Verbesserung der Situation in Katar
auszuführen und bei nicht erreichen der
sportlichen Ziele sollen die Erlöse an
Menschenrechtsorganisationen gespendet
werden DFB-Präsident Bernd Neuendorf der
hat heute das hier auf einer
Pressekonferenz angekündigt
ich finde die Mannschaft hat in der
Vergangenheit und in den vergangenen
Monaten wenn man das über die Strecke
sieht immer wieder Zeichen gesetzt und
das bitte ich auch wirklich
zu honorieren wir haben ja das ging ja
schon los unmittelbar nach dem letzten
Bundestag und nach meiner Wahl dass wir
Menschenrechtsorganisationen zu
Länderspielen dazu gezogen haben wo sie
mit den Spielern diskutiert haben wo sie
sie auf die Situation
hier im Land aber auch ganz generell zum
Thema Menschenrechte diskutiert wurde
wir haben den menschenrechtskongress
gemacht wir haben mit anderen Ländern
die
bindevereinbart es gab übrigens auch
immer wieder
Zeichen der Mannschaft jetzt zuletzt
auch in Interviews die sich klar
positioniert haben und ich möchte nicht
ausschließen dass es während des
Turnierverlaufs dann auch noch die ein
oder andere Aktion gibt
Felix Frage an dich wir hören das da hat
der DFB-Präsident Bernd Neuendorf gesagt
man habe Zeichen gesendet auch die
Spieler vielleicht auch Frage an dich
wie schwierig siehst du das aktuell für
die Spielersicht zu positionieren in dem
ganzen oder was würdest du da vielleicht
auch wünschen
ja gut ich finde die Spieler müssen sich
erstmal auf sportliche fokussieren und
sind aber dann halt auch ja am endkanal
quasi dran und das Sprachrohr nach außen
vom DFB weil sie Interviews geben für
mich macht hier ein auch ein riesen
Fehler einfach die FIFA weil ich finde
Regenbogen kapitänsbinden wurden z.B
angefragt von DFB ähm was ein Schritt
ist in diese Richtung und ähm was
abgelehnt wurde von Katar und ich finde
der Fehler hat 2010 begonnen und man
hatte 12 Jahre Zeit als FIFA mit Katar
zu kommunizieren dass es Dinge geben
wird die darauf stoßen und das dass man
das dass wir im Westen weitaus liberaler
im im Hinblick auf vielleicht ähm
Homosexualität oder Frauenrechten und
Menschenrechten sind
ist ein Fakt und die FIFA hatte den
Auftrag das zu kommunizieren und jetzt
sind wir 12 Jahre später an dem Punkt
dass in Katar die aus gibt getätigt wird
das Homosexualität ein geistiger Schaden
ist da wo ich mir denke die FIFA hat
einfach zwölf Jahre ihre Aufgabe nicht
gemacht ja es wurden Stadium gebaut ja
es wurde eine WM logistisch vorbereitet
aber man hat 12 Jahre Zeit gehabt so
etwas vorzubereiten dass so eine Aussage
nicht getätigt wird und ich ich kann
Frau büchsner nur zustimmen wir haben
eine Riesenchance vertan zu
kommunizieren ein Dialog herzustellen
zwischen verschiedenen Ansichten was was
Homosexualität betrifft was Frauenrechte
betrifft wir sind im besten oder in
Europa weitaus liberaler in in diesen
Dingen und die FIFA hat es einfach nicht
geschafft 12 Jahre lang und jetzt sind
wir an dem Punkt ähm das z.B auch
Dänemark die ja mit einer Aufschrift auf
dem Trikot ähm darauf aufmerksam machen
wollten für Menschenrechte und auch für
Frauenrechte für Homosexualität und auch
das wurde abgelehnt von von Katar wo ich
einfach sage ist es wird versucht aber
es wird jetzt
vor kurzem einfach versucht und zwölf
Jahre hat ein Dialog zwischen mit der
FIFA einfach nicht stattgefunden und das
ist zu kritisieren du sprichst da auch
weitere Zeichen von weiteren
Nationalmannschaften einen vielleicht
können wir das auch zeigen die
Niederlande und auch die englische
Nationalmannschaft sie haben einen
gemeinsames Training mit Gastarbeitern
aus Kata veranstaltet und die
Niederlande sie will auch zusätzlich
nach jedem Spiel ihre Trikots für eine
Verbesserung der Situation
versteigern Frau Büchs mich wird von
ihnen auch noch mal interessieren wie
sie sozusagen die Stufen der
Verantwortlichkeit und auch diese
Zeichen sehen also wie ordnen Sie
vielleicht als erstes die Rolle des DFB
und auch der Nationalspieler jetzt ein
ja das ist eine der schwierigsten Fragen
weil die tatsächliche Entscheidung ja
bei der FIFA lag und ich kenne die
Beziehung des DFB und der FIFA nicht gut
genug um mir dann Urteil zu erlauben das
heißt ich spreche jetzt mal über die
Situation jetzt
und da ist es schon tatsächlich auch so
insbesondere was die Spieler anbelangt
dass nun mal die Entscheidung getroffen
ist die fahren dahin das ist der Job
und für die Spieler ist das eine extrem
schwierige Situation die sehe ich
dennoch weil sie nun mal die Profis sind
die in diesem Umfeld arbeiten in der
Verantwortung sehr sehr klare Zeichen zu
setzen da würde ich mir auch noch mehr
wünschen ich habe gehört es ist sind
irgendwelche Dinge geplant oder
angekündigt also ich bin wirklich
gespannt
da muss man als diejenigen die da Geld
verdienen letztlich in diesem in dem
ganzen Bereich
kann man durchaus noch kerniger sich
positionieren der Verband ist noch mal
eine andere Frage weil das ist eben eine
von den Institutionen die ja sozusagen
zum Teil auch an Präsidien und so weiter
in der FIFA beteiligt sind und das ist
wenn man so will die Art
Berufsvertretung und da sehe ich auch
noch eine stärkere Verantwortung da sehe
ich vor allem die Verantwortung nach
hinten also da sind ganz ganz sicher
Möglichkeiten verpasst worden wo man
hätte eben Bedingungen zum Beispiel
stellen können das hatte Dario gerade
als Beispiel gebracht und das zweite ist
was macht man jetzt in Zukunft ja es
werden ja wieder Entscheidungen anstehen
ich bin relativ hoffnungsvoll dass diese
WM nicht spurlos bleibt also das ist ja
das hat schon einen Effekt das hat auch
durchaus glaube ich ein globalen Effekt
in den Medien jedenfalls in der
Wahrnehmung in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung dass das eine WM ist die
anders ist als andere und da sehe ich
den DFB z.B wirklich in der
Verantwortung sich zu überlegen für die
Zukunft
wie kann man a verhindern dass eine
solche Entscheidung noch mal getroffen
wird und B wie können wir stärker
Strukturen haben wir können wir klarere
Kante zeigen wir können wir bessere
Bedingungen haben dass wir nicht mit
unserem tollen Sport in der Situation
kommen wo man eben solche Aussagen hört
oder wo tatsächlich Menschen einfach
Angst haben und dieses fußball ist für
alle da einfach überhaupt nicht gilt
Dario das Leid ich auch noch mal an dich
weiter die Sache der
Verantwortlichkeiten auch der Spieler
der Verbände wie siehst du
ich sage Ihnen viel Diskussionen
eigentlich hätte game not a players die
die Jungs die darunter fliegen und ihren
Beruf nachgehen die haben das nicht
ausgesucht die sind nicht das Problem
die Verantwortung liegt tatsächlich viel
bei der FIFA und den Verbänden
tatsächlich kommt mir der DFB da auch zu
gut weg
natürlich ich ich sehe schon auch da
auch Bernd Neuendorfer macht wirklich
mehr als viele seiner Vorgänger es gibt
schon auch Mutmacher aber
die WM 2006 wurde auch durch Produktion
nach Deutschland gebracht und dieser
Ausverkauf des Fußballs dass man einfach
alles kaufen kann sich alle damit
abgefunden haben ja auch FIFA ist kaputt
das ist kein Kavaliers liegt das ist
nicht 8006 aber wir hatten noch ein
tolles Sommermärchen ja aber alles schön
nein da steht in einer geraden Linie
wenn man einfach nur alles verkauft dann
verkauft man es irgendwann an alles und
und achtet noch nicht mal mehr auf
Menschenleben auf wirklich die die
krassesten Auswüchse wo wo
Menschenrechte
seit Jahren aller Kerne befasst sind und
deswegen
steht der DFB gerade dadurch dass er
sich in diesem Jahrtausend selber eine
WM gekauft hat noch viel mehr in der
Verantwortung aber das Übel ist ist auf
jeden Fall die FIFA und da kann man auch
ein bisschen die katharische Sichtweise
verstehen dass immer sagen warum schaut
ihr immer auf uns natürlich alles sehr
richtig gesagt die die Probleme sind da
aber dieser Situation jetzt der
Ausverkauf des Fußballs das ist Schuld
der FIFA ich habe immer wieder auch den
Blick in die Kommentare von euch dabei
CB der schreibt bei Youtube ich lasse
mir die Leidenschaft zum Fußball nicht
nehmen deshalb gucke ich die WM ein
weiterer Kommentar kommt von Chris
pankrets auch so ein bisschen in die
Richtung von uns ich werde alle Top
Spiele schauen ist sein Zitat sie nicht
zuschauen würde nichts ändern weil ARD
und ZDF schon vor vielen Jahren die
Rechte dafür erworben haben wenn die
Spiele nicht schaut bezahlt sie trotzdem
vielleicht da wichtig zu Klarstellung
können wir die Argumentation auch von
den Kollegen des ZDF-Sportstudios einmal
einblenden damit das auch einmal
transparent ist hier steht auf Instagram
die Positionierung der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk hat den
Auftrag über Ereignisse von erheblicher
Bedeutung zu berichten dazu zählt die
Fußball-WM sowohl der Sport als auch die
politischen und gesellschaftlichen
Rahmenbedingungen unter den er
stattfindet und auch eine Zusatz es ist
unsere Aufgabe die Realität abzubilden
Missstände offenzulegen wir boykottieren
die WM deshalb nicht im Gegenteil wir
schauen besonders genau hin und
berichten was schief läuft wie z.B die
ZDF Dokumentation Geheimsache Kata da
haben wir auch die Ausschnitte gesehen
und auch im Programm jetzt über die WM
soll es so sein dass sowohl die
sportlichen Leistungen der Mannschaft
und Spieler eingeordnet werden parallel
machen wir aber als ZDF mit politischen
und gesellschaftlichen berichten auch
weiter während der WM auf diese
Situation in Katar aufmerksam
das soweit zu der Frage des Users mich
würde jetzt noch mal der Blick auch auf
die Zukunft in Bezug auf Lösungsansätze
interessieren das haben sie Frau Büchs
auch schon thematisiert sie haben sich
selber auch persönlich mit Sport
ethischen Themen in der Vergangenheit
auseinandergesetzt und es gibt ja das
sehen wir auch in den Chats noch ein
paar unentschiedene User wie soll man
jetzt damit umgehen welche Tipps haben
Sie denn für Leute die noch nicht ihre
Entscheidung getroffen haben
also der beste Tipp wenn man eine
Entscheidung treffen möchte also ich
finde das auch noch mal wichtig zu sagen
individuell kann man auch sich nicht im
ethischen Dilemma sehen weil man
sozusagen ganz am Ende dieser
Entscheidungskette steht das finde ich
echt legitim finde ich noch mal wichtig
zu sagen aber wenn man sich da unsicher
ist das beste ist einfach
durchzusprechen mit ganz vielen Leuten
sich ganz viele Positionen zu holen das
mit denen zu besprechen den es wichtig
ist und dann eben zu überlegen was
während für mich Ansätze also es gibt ja
alles mögliche es gibt dieses ein Euro
pro Spenden es gibt Theater die machen
Aufführungen statt Fußball gucken gehen
ins Theater das kann man sozusagen mixen
Schatzi mein Spielern geht mal ins
Theater also es gibt wirklich viele
unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten und die
sind ja auch lokal ganz unterschiedlich
und ich würde wie bei allen ethischen
Fragen die einen persönlich angehen ist
es das wirklich beste sich viel
auszutauschen und sich ganz viel ganz
viel reinzuholen
vielleicht haben Sie auch noch sozusagen
Modelle aus der Gegenwart von
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie die das
aktuell bewerten auch im ethischen
Kontext was gibt's da für
Lösungsstrategien
gibt es da was wo man sich auch noch mal
vielleicht einlesen kann
ja also es gibt eine relativ große Sport
Ethik und diese verschiedenen Positionen
und diese verschiedenen Schattierung der
Verantwortung die wir heute jetzt
besprochen haben die stehen da auch noch
mal drin halt theoretischer und und
sozusagen komplexer und mit einer mit
einer tieferen Begründung und es gibt
eben tatsächlich unterschiedliche
Ansätze es gibt diejenigen die ganz klar
die geradlinigsten argumentieren und
sagen wann immer ein Sport Ereignis
stattfindet in einem sagen wir
autokratischen System oder in einer
Situation wo Menschenrechte verletzt
werden ist die rote Linie Schluss da ist
jede Lust da ist jeder Sport das Eis
vorbei und dann gibt's diejenigen die
eben abwägen ihre Position einnehmen und
sagen man muss auch man muss immer den
ganz konkreten Kontext sich anschauen
wie viel kann man noch ändern und
insbesondere was sind für die jeweils
betroffenen die Schäden und da denkt man
dann einmal individuell nach also es ist
auch nicht nichts zu sagen Sport gehört
zu meinem Leben das ist Teil meiner das
muss nicht mal der Beruf sein sondern es
ist Teil meiner Lebensqualität es gehört
zu meiner mentalen Gesundheit mich da
irgendwie abzureagieren also da gibt es
ganz ganz viele unterschiedliche Wege
sozusagen raus zu schattieren was sind
jetzt jeweils die die Betroffenheiten
und die Belastung und dann wägt man das
eben ab und ich habe das jetzt sozusagen
alles ein bisschen flotter gemacht mit
diesem Beispielen aber am Ende des Tages
bemüht man sich eigentlich darum einen
Weg zu finden
letztlich nicht wirklich lösbare
ethische Dilemmata so klären und
deswegen noch mal der Verweis darauf
dass die Entscheidungsfindung dass für
die Zukunft wirklich besser werden
sollte Dankeschön trotzdem für Ihre
Anregungen und Tipps in Sachen
Entscheidungsfindung und auch die
Betrachtungsweise von der ethischen
Perspektive alle Lena bügst die
Vorsitzende des deutschen etikats danke
schön für ihre Zeit sie haben noch ein
paar Termine super dass Sie sich die
Zeit heute hier bei uns genommen haben
vielen Dank hat mich gefreut tschüss
Felix und Dario mit euch möchte ich noch
ein bisschen weitermachen weiter
diskutieren auch mit Blick auf die Frage
wie schaffen wir es jetzt sozusagen in
Zukunft die Liebe zum Fußball die das
kann ich auch von mir persönlich sagen
uns alle drei verbindet schon schon seit
Kindertagen dass die sozusagen durch
solche Ereignisse nicht kaputt gemacht
wird Felix da würde ich ganz gerne mit
dir beginnen wie was wünscht du dir da
mit Blick auf die Zukunft mit Blick auf
die Situation rund um solche
Weltmeisterschaften dass man eben auch
das Gefühl wieder hat
euphorisch zu sein bei der WM und die
Werte zu leben die der Fußball vorgibt
nämlich dass er für alle ist
ja das im Endeffekt glaube ich die ganze
Welt so denkt wie du es gerade gesagt
hast nämlich dass der Fußball für alle
ist ich glaube das ist ein Prozess der
einfach Zeit erfordert und das finde ich
hat man auch bei uns in Deutschland
gesehen wenn man 10 20 Jahre zurückdenkt
haben wir gerade etwas das Thema
Homosexualität betrifft ein
Riesenfortschritt gemacht und auch
trotzdem finde ich sind wir da noch
nicht am Ziel ähm mir fehlen auch immer
noch Männer die sich als homosexuell
auch im Fußballprofi Bereich da ist der
Frauenfußball schon wesentlich weiter
also auch wir sind noch in einem Prozess
drin und ich würde mir einfach wünschen
dass dass man weltweit einfach diesen
Prozess voranbringt und den Dialog
herstellt und ähm ja die FIFA hat
natürlich die Aufgabe bei den nächsten
Weltmeisterschaften ein ja
Anforderungskatalog
darzustellen der sowas klarstellt dass
der Fußball für alle da ist und das ist
halt auch das Versäumnis was jetzt in
Katar stattgefunden hat Felix sprichst
du glaube ich auch Problem an die ist
auch ja in der Männerdomäne Fußball auch
bei uns gibt also auch die Frage an dich
was würdest du dir da Wünschen mit Blick
auf die Zukunft ja absolut aber schon
mal weil Felix Ausführung fußball ist
einfach alles fußball ist Leben fußball
ist so ein geiler Sport denn
lasse ich mir lassen wir uns garantiert
nicht von
von Produkt Machenschaften kaputt machen
aber wir müssen schon irgendwo sehen
wir lieben den Fußball wem gehört der
Fußball der Fußball musste Menschen
gehören die lieben die Fans die alle die
die Spieler an alle die Herzblut
reinbringen die müssten mehr Gehör
finden und da sind wir in Deutschland ja
eigentlich ganz gut aufgestellt diese 50
+ 1 Regel das also die Vereine an sich
in der
demokratische Hand ihre Mitglieder sein
müssen
damit im Fußball irgendwo die Menschen
im Mittelpunkt stehen weil die
Entwicklung die wir jetzt gesehen haben
dass immer mehr die entscheiden die
einfach nur im Fußball ein
kapitalanlageobjekt sehen einfach nur
massig Geld rein und in zehn Jahren habe
ich noch mal mehr Geld oder Akteure wie
Katar die
dialogischen Interesse haben wir haben
so so viel Negatives so recht auf Katar
geschaut die katarische Sichtweise als
kleines Land zwischen den Großmächten
Saudi Arabien Iran irgendwie nicht nicht
einfach zerbaum zu werden da passiert
ist einfach nur weil viel Öl da ist das
Interesse auf die Weltbühne zu kommen
es ist absolut logisch aber der Fußball
muss ich fragen lass ich mich vor jedem
Karren spannen da wird mit viel Geld
geredet der Fußball ist da der Fußball
könnte ja auch sagen ja wie wir sehen
euer Anliegen wir haben auch nichts
dagegen dass man eine WM in der
arabischen Welt stattfindet auch dieses
das winterding oder das Bier Ding da
sind ja nicht die wirklich wichtigen
Sachen natürlich könnte man dass man
aber was man sagt wenn ihr das wollt
dann gibt es klare Regeln zum Beispiel
Strafbarkeit von Homosexualität ist ein
No-Go dann braucht man sich gar nicht
bewerben
Ausbeutung auf den auf den Baustellen
also Sachen müssen einfach klar
definiert sein und im Großen und Ganzen
geht es darum dass die dass die Basis
oder einfach schöner gesagt die Straße
sich den Fußball zurückholt und das ist
das ist teilweise wirklich lange
anstrengende Arbeit aber es geht am Ende
kann man nur sagen werdet werdet
Mitglied in den Verein bringt euch da
ein und und sorgt dafür dass das eine
Mitgliederbasis im Verein entscheidet
den der Verein am Herz liegt und und
nicht nur Kapitalinteressen das ist auf
der Eins Ebene das gleiche Problem wie
jetzt noch mal hör skaliert auf dieser
geopolitischen Ebene mit so einem großen
werturnier Felix Dario beschreibt er
auch die die Aufgabe von jedem einzelnen
ähm danke auch liebe Userinnen und User
dass er immer noch dabei seid ihr
schreibt auch noch fleißig in die Chats
zum Beispiel ist ein Kommentar der so
ein bisschen aber in die andere Richtung
geht ja schon bisschen
illusioniert er sagt es geht hier
sowieso nur um Macht und Geld da ist
kein Sinn für Menschenrechte und keine
liberalen Ideen was absurd ist Felix was
würdest du dem User sagen sozusagen das
vielleicht diese Hoffnungslosigkeit da
nicht mehr bei ihm vorherrscht
ja ich glaube dass die
Hoffnungslosigkeit kann man so ein
bisschen dadurch auslöschen dass man
sieht das schon Prozess stattgefunden
hat und auch dass wir in Deutschland
durch die 50+1 Regel auch schon anderen
Ländern voraus sind also es findet ein
Prozess statt aber dieser Prozess ist
glaube ich vielen nicht schnell genug
und man muss auch immer darauf achten
dass gerade das Finanzielle wodurch der
Fußball sich gerade auch wodurch der
Fußball stark ist ähm dadurch hat der
Fußball auch viele Vorteile ähm es ein
ein sehr professionalisierter Sport
viele
Menschen haben durch den Fußball die
Chance hauptberuflich davon zu leben
also es ist ein Sport der auch sehr
kommerzialisiert ist und der Sport
profitiert auch in vielen Bereichen
davon aber das was Dario gerade gesagt
hat stimmt natürlich auch es wird immer
skaliert es wird geguckt wie viel Geld
steckt man rein wie viel Geld kriege ich
raus diese Denkweise muss man ein
bisschen differenzieren und zu sagen was
unterstützt den Sport wirklich und was
ist aber die Sichtweise aus ja aus quasi
Invest personensicht dass man sagt man
kriegt mehr Geld als man
reingesteckt hat und noch mal auf deine
Frage zurückzukommen
ich würde einfach sagen dass man gucken
muss dass man beim Sport bleibt und auch
aktiv Fußball liebt und auf der Straße
kickt also dass man quasi Weg
guckt von von all den Zahlen und ja
wieder beim Fußball landet auch wenn das
nicht immer einfach ist und ja wie man
jetzt auch bei der WM sieht ja für
Kritik sorgt Eindrücke Einschätzung und
Ausblicke aus den aus den Herzen von
Dario Minden und auch von Felix casalino
vielen Dank euch beiden für eure Zeit
für eure Diskussion zur Frage wer hat
noch Bock auf diese Fußball-WM danke
schön
Dankeschön auch an euch liebe Userinnen
und User für Smidt diskutieren fürs
Fragen stellen für eure Position die ihr
eingebracht habt wir hoffen dass wir
auch noch Tipps für die
Entscheidungsfindung vielleicht geben
konnten Perspektiven aufzeigen konnten
Fakten noch mal präsentieren konnten
auch mit dem Blick ins Land Cutter
dankeschön fürs zuschauen danke schön
für den Moment und bis zum nächsten Mal
hier bei ZDF heute live ciao